[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'audio
je vais vous parler de casques de casque
intra auriculaire
je vais vous parler des petites bottes
free alors les flics font du fric facile
vous connaissez c'est la société de mode
veille qui fait aussi la tiguan pro je
vous ai présenté il ya déjà quelques
temps qui fait ses écouteurs intra
auriculaires qui sont sans rappeler les
airs pop d'apple heures cette igp aux
free existe dans plusieurs couleurs pour
croire qu'ils ont pensé à la france
championne du monde en bleu en blanc je
les ai pas et on rouge alors c'était
claude frissons franchement super cool
et pour plusieurs raisons
ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui c'est
de jeter un coup d'oeil à ces types aux
frimas les écouteurs fin du coup moi j'y
vais les écouter et vous expliquer pour
tout vous dire j'ai des coûts déjà
depuis quelques jours puisque ils sont
là ça fait un petit moment que je les
teste les essaye et je les trouve assez
cool
franchement voyez que je les mélange de
jeu de mon temps où j'étais heureuse
strictement plus rien je trouve vraiment
cool très intéressante c'est une très
belle alternative aux ipod d'apple
d'autant plus qu'ils sont complètement
compatible ios et android
enfin voila je vous explique tout ça et
vous me direz vous ce que vous en pensez
en commentaire texpos de free rouge type
box free noir alors j'ai déjà ouvert les
rouges et pour tout vous dire
voilà le contenu vous avez donc cette
petit étui dans lequel vous mettez vos
petites pauses free qui vont venir se
recharger en gros c'est un peu comme dr
paul tout simplement vous prenez votre
peau d'esprit ils viennent trouver leur
place très très très très facilement
vous refermez vous le prenez avec
l'élastique voulant emmener partout il
est en bandoulière s'écoule en plus là
ce qui est cool c'est directement dans
la boîte
ils vont se recharger votre type mode
free tout seul il a donné quatre heures
quasiment 4 heures d'autonomie musicale
mais lorsque vous le mettez dedans que
vous le recharger comme ça vous avez en
tout jusqu'à 18 heures vous pouvez
utiliser quatre bonne foi sans aucun
problème ce sens même partout ça se
baladent fait ce que vous voulez c'est
franchement hyper cool ici vous le
recharger en micro usb et alors là c'est
marrant parce que vous avez du micro usb
et là vous avez de l'usb type c bon
pourquoi pas après vous prenez un câble
classique que vous avez chez vous si
vous voulez micro usb ça marchera
parfaitement bien
autre truc qui coule à l'intérieur de la
boîte
lorsque vous ouvrez complètement up bon
vous est forcément ça qui est aussi à
l'intérieur
mais vous avez aussi alors ça pour la
consternation
on s'en fiche un peu vous avez surtout
ce petit sachet avec d'autres dimensions
de bouchons pour vos oreilles
ce qui fait ça pour s'adapter à toutes
les morphologies mois celle là les plus
grandes me vont très bien c'est parfait
que vous détailler les usages mais ce
qui est super cool c'est toute cette
partie là c'est une partie tactile qui
vous servira à monter le son à baisser
le son vous appuyez de fois vous mettez
en post.fr pas mal de choses
les deux sont complètement tactile je
vais vous développez vous allez voir
franchement c'est cool
à la question est ce que ces petites
pâtisseries sont faits pour les sportifs
la réponse est très clairement oui
les zones certification ip57 va être
résistant à l'eau à la sueur
alors évitez forcément d'aller vous
baigner dans une piscine avec parce que
là ça va pas du tout le faire mais vous
les mettez pour le sport vous transpirez
sanaa sera absolument parfaitement sans
aucun problème il trouve très facilement
leur place dans les oreilles se situe
idéalement sont vraiment vraiment
résistants alors je vais pas faire un
bongo mais lorsque vous allez faire du
score vous faites pas ça et ça bouge pas
du tout ça franchement c'est hyper hyper
hyper cool il tient très bien d'un côté
même de l'autre donc de ce point de vue
là en terme de tenue et si toutefois je
vous le disais c'est une fois ça va pas
votre oreille bien vous avez qu à
changer cette petite partie doit mettre
une plus petite et ça ira pour les
oreilles sont un peu plus petit
franchement comme ça c'est cool alors là
la couleur rouge
franchement c'est une couleur qui
claquent mais elle se trouve ça hyper
hyper efficace personnellement j'ai
beaucoup donc en terme de tenue au
niveau de l'appareil
j'ai absolument aucun souci là je me
fais un petit test duo avec rammstein
dans les oreilles ne voulait pas trop
six pales force parce que j'entends
absolument rien en fait ce qui est cool
avec les typos d'esprit c'est dès que
j'en avais 20 sam et la pause oui
quelqu'un dans la rue par exemple vous
écoutez votre musique rock vous enlever
ça mais la pause
et lorsque vous remettez forcément la
musique repart de plus belle alors
j'enlève pour vous prenez ça ira quand
même mieux vous appuyé deux fois ça
passe au morceau suivant autre point
intéressant vous ville c'est là vers le
haut ça monte le son vous baissez la
sagesse le saura ça va tout de suite
beaucoup mieux vous voulez remonter
voilà ça vous montre le sont
progressivement cet acte il s'écoule ça
marche y parvient lorsque vous êtes un
coup de fil c'est pareil vous double tap
et ça répond vous devez taper ça
raccroche savoure mais la musique
maintenant il faut savoir que les types
of three sont aussi compatibles avec
google
la assistant avec série avec amazon avec
ça ce que vous avez juste à faire
lorsque vous voulez l'utiliser vous avez
forcément votre musique voulait
s'appuyer deux secondes là ça vous
active ici alors ici c'est google
assistance a peut être ce que vous
voulez ça marche très bien et ensuite ça
me remettre à la musique
vous voulez mettre la poste il ya notre
moyen qui marche très très bien vous
mettez comme ça vous laissez votre doigt
appuyé pendant deux secondes
sané la pause vous voulez remettre
lecture fait exactement la même chose
vous vous posez là vous laissez votre
doigt appuyé pendant 2 secondes et sa
part parce que ces quelques petits
gestes sont assez marrant mais en tout
cas ça c'est pas mal au niveau de
l'expérience
c'est vrai que le côté des fois qu'il
fait un peu pas hyper hyper pratique
vous rencontrez quelqu'un vous dit je
vais prier pendant deux secondes
attendait à temps à des bons le mieux
c'est les enlever directement
vous pouvez bien évidemment les utiliser
ensemble pour passer un coup de fil mais
si vous voulez utiliser qu'un seul vous
pouvez par contre ça sera uniquement
droit parce que c'est sur celui de droit
déjà d'une que vous avez un micro donc
si vous mettez celui de gauche là ça a
été un petit peu compliqué mais surtout
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que votre
téléphone
il se connecte avec celui de droite et
ensuite celui de droit quand vous le
signalent à celui de gauche donc
forcément celui là qui va être connecté
à votre smartphone vous le prenez vous
posez peut passer un coup de fil
lorsque vous voulez voilà ça c'est
franchement cool maintenant on va parler
de qualité audio c'est vrai que le son
est quand même pas mal alors après sur
des petits haut parleurs comme ça c'est
pas là vous allez avoir un spectre hyper
hyper large
vous allez forcément avoir les aigus
sont bien les médiums très bien les
graves correct par contre vous avez pas
de basse fatalement avec des petits
écouteurs comme ça elle va pouvoir
développer beaucoup de puissance
beaucoup de grave
beaucoup de trucs qui envoie un peu du
bois par contre la qualité elle est ok
elle fait le job
personnellement voilà je trouve que ça
marche ça marche bien je couds se sont
vous entendez pas un espèce de truc
c'est assez ou trop cher votre carte no
deep techno allemande
c'est assez énorme après ils ont aussi
une petite réduction de bruit alors
c'est pas une réduction de bruit énorme
quand vous pourriez avoir sur des gros
casque sony ou boys c'est pas quelque
chose qui va vraiment vous isolez mais
qui valent néanmoins coupé un petit peu
de l'extérieur alors je pense qu a déjà
un effet un peu mécanique lorsque vous
le mettez comme ça ça vient bien bouché
les oreilles
en tout cas moi je sais moi cela
prendrait moins bien donc je pense que
ça c'est un point qui est très très fort
et puis je pense effectivement il y
aussi une petite réduction de bruit
dessus c'est pas énorme mais en tout cas
ça a le mérite d'être là et franchement
c'est pas mal et après en terme de
puissance
on a suffisamment de sang pour en
profiter là je le sens qui est poussé à
fond ça va après si j'ai poussé beaucoup
plus fort j'aime rendre complètement
sourd et franchement c'est pas du tout
le but du jeu et je vous le déconseille
fortement
je le dis souvent et je leur dis faites
gaffe fait gaffe fait gaffe je sais je
répète trois fois fait bien par quatre
fois il faut vraiment faire attention à
ses oreilles pas écouter de la musique
trop longtemps à des volumes beaucoup
trop fort parce qu'à force complètement
sourd et croyez-moi ça arrive plus vite
qu'en pensent ces petits écouteurs
fonctionne avec du bluetooth 4.2 qualité
franchement c'est pas mal les éditeurs
prennent vraiment bien l'oreille le fait
que vous puissiez les ja mettre la
pression
j'ai de la techno allemande dans les
aurès le fait que vous puissiez les
utiliser pour aller faire du sport
franchement ça s'est super bien j'aime
bien le look il rappelle vraiment
l'airpod d'apple va pas se mentir mais
je trouve que le look est franchement
cool
il ya vraiment un côté très premium en
rouge comme ça on va davantage les voir
si vous les prenez en noir ça va être
forcément un peu plus discret mais je
trouve que voilà il ya eu un très très
bon boulot tu fais là dessus par un
autre vol et je vous dis le point
positif c'est que vous pouvez vraiment
les utiliser sur ios sur android ça
s'est vraiment bien
l'autonomie est cool quatre heures des
coups de quasiment 4 heures des coûte
rien comme ça c'est franchement khoury
lorsque vous vous déplacez que vous êtes
en voyage
vouloir changer là dedans il faut 45
minutes de recharge pour les recharger
complètement mais déjà en 15 minutes
vous allez pouvoir goûter plus d'une
heure de musique donc déjà franchement
ça sera vraiment bien à faire n'attendez
pas le son c'est dommage je peux pas le
mettre à l'épreuve le droit d'auteur
mais là je me croirais ancrée
lorsque j'étais en face c'est tout
simplement énorme
ah j'adore cette épicerie tout 129 euros
99 je n'entend absolument pas j'écoute
de la musique électro elle me français
est juste énormissime
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire est ce que vous avez déjà
des produits de mode boy est ce que vous
avez testé les petites peaux d'esprit
est ce qui pourrait vous faire l'oeil
s'il vous intéresse je vous ai mis un
lien on va dans la description vous va
les acheter directement sur le site de
maubeuge
moi je les trouve vraiment très très
cool alors vous m'en voulez pas un gp
retrouvez de faire une petite session de
danse électro puis quand j'entre vous je
vous invite à me rejoindre sur youtube à
vous abonner puis on va parler vachement
d'odieux on va parler de plein de choses
il ya plein de plein de surprises qui
arrive
il ya de la trottinette ya des
smartphones et du gaming ya plein de
choses hélas assez cool là
[Musique]